hey everyone it's Michael BOS from
orderflows and this is the orderflows
market analysis for Thursday June 6
2017 and tomorrow just ah heads up I do
have a webinar I'm doing you can sign up
for it down below the link is in the
description and I'll be talking about
how order flow can give you an edge in
your trading you know I'm always uh
talking about how order flow can help
you out I'm going to show you some nice
examples um actually that came from
today I'm not going to I'm not going to
talk about the big one but I'm going to
talk about a couple of the other
examples um very similar to what I'll be
talking about in the webinar and if you
can't attend that's fine just uh sign up
and at least you'll be on the the email
list for uh the dist for the replay so
you can watch the replay over the
weekend or whenever you want now um
tomorrow is uh the first Friday of July
uh July 7th um July 1st was on a
Saturday that's why it seems a bit late
but um and you got the jobs report
coming out
and you know ADP numbers came out uh the
other day and showed companies adding
fewer workers to payrolls than uh than
the prior month so you know again I'm
going to I'm curious to see how this job
number comes out I'm not going to trade
it but um I don't trade the jobs numbers
but I'm always I always like to watch it
I I do think
uh you know stronger than expected uh
number may give further uh impetus to a
sell off in the bonds um basically amid
you got hawkish Central Bank comments um
ECB minutes furthered that Trend policy
makers last month to open the door to
dropping from their dropping from their
message the their basically
long-standing
chitchat of to expand or extend the
banks Bond purchase program if necessary
um in uh in other news uh crude oil
added another 39 cents um Rising us
production and uh it's basically
dampening enthusiasm over declining uh
crude in gas stock piles but again you
know hey gas is uh at like 12E lows you
know at the pump which which is the
important thing and you know I don't
think that's a bad thing as a consumer
but
um you know and I think that will also
help spur the economy a little bit so
but anyway you know I digress you know I
talk about fundamentals um just to sort
of give you a bit of a background but
before I jump in a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only and is not
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a futes contract or make any of the type
investment decision future training
contain to St a risk is not for every
investor an investor can potentially
lose all or more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
could be lost without jeopardizing one's
Financial Security or lifestyle only
risk Capital should be used for trading
and only those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results tools I use
in this presentation are the order flows
Trader and the Delta scalper so let's uh
Jump Right In here really quick uh first
I talk about the five years and five
years saw some nice movement early in
the morning and you know just go back
down here to uh the low of the day here
714 you've got a ratio you don't have a
Divergence you still got negative Delta
look at this you got some very
supportive buying going on down here
6,000 here 4,000 here you got a couple
buying and balances off this low um even
you know coming you know slightly before
it you know I always like to see what
the volumes were when you're hitting the
lows earlier there were some decent ones
but not as strong as you're seeing down
here now I I talk about this trade setup
um in in one of the PDFs ebooks whatever
you want to call it that I had
distributed uh when I first released the
orderflows trade it's called what I call
the o2x trade and what it is is you have
a ratio on the low or a ratio on the
high you look for a pullback within two
ticks of this low I mean it can be you
know up to two ticks it can be right on
this low again but you know ideally
where you're going to place your limit
is two ticks off this low so you'll be
getting in here at this low is 117 13
and A4 you should be getting you know
put a limit in to buy it at 117 13 and 3
quarters and it trades there it trades
one lot you wouldn't have been filled
trades another hits it again here a few
minutes later this is 714 it's
719 and you you probably would have been
filled here because you know it did go
offer here so you know you definitely
would have been filled if you weren't
filled there you'd been filled over here
at
729 as you came down and you hit the low
again right you test the low so the o2x
trade what you do is you have a ratio
don't have a Divergence put a bid in two
ticks away from that low or if it was a
high it would be two ticks off the high
your stop is just right below the low so
you're buying it two ticks above the low
right here at 117 13 and 3/4 comes down
to a quarter you're risking three ticks
on this trade basically you know so your
stops at 11713 your entries at 17 13 and
3/4 boom you get filled here actually
rallies up here you get filled for sure
if you if if you doubt that you would
have been filled here but you would have
because it was offered
there and you know from so from
11713 and 3 quarters you can see here it
traded up to 15 and and and a quarter
but you know here this is a big move you
know if if if you're still in it you're
getting you know it's a move from 117 13
and 3/4 all the way up to here 117 you
know 18 basically right up in here you
get the Delta scalper giving you a sell
signal and the market starts selling off
rallies back up towards the area you
know we don't get up to the high of that
bar on the Delta scalper your stop would
be just behind this high so you're still
in the trade and it sells off back down
towards your low again you know down
here you got point of control at the
bottom which is very bullish you got a
bullish ratio as well and we rally back
up up up up you got the Delta scaler but
it's giving you a sell on on a green
candle so you know you shouldn't be
taking it so you know there was some
really nice you know orderflow trading
opportunities these are things I talk
about every day well maybe not the o2x I
don't really talk about that much uh
unless you're in the
room but um you know this this is
something this is a trade setup that
I've I've put out there for years
already that you know people do use and
you know if you used it today in the 5
years it give you a nice trade but if
you're using the Delta scalper boom you
know right up here on the
right where the market turns right here
and sells off down towards your low
bullish ratio Point control on the
bottom another thing I talk about every
day you know these are the same things I
talk about every day it's not like I'm
just and in the same markets right I
talk about five years I talk about bonds
I talk about Euro currency Japanese Yen
e minis those are the markets I talk
about every day so you know these are
the same things you see me talking about
sometimes I I feel like I'm just talking
about the same thing over and over but
you know these things occur daily so if
you're not using order flow you're
really um
hly leaving money on the table but you
know you're missing um you're missing
some nice Yum Yum Yum Yum trades yum yum
is a term they like to use in Singapore
to describe um you know basically slam
dunk trading
opportunities okay now uh we'll go back
here in the bonds this
morning and you know go back to around
the 7 o'cl time
here um what do you got here you know
6:30 you do have the Delta scalper
giving you a buy right on the low but it
comes back immediately with the bearish
ratio you know again had you taken this
you'd have been stopped out I mean
honestly I would like to take this these
are the type of Trades I like to take
right off the low but you know as luck
would have it there's still some selling
coming in so yeah it would have been
stopped out it's not the end of the
world um but anyway um you just wait for
the next trade you know I'm not just
going to show you trades that um you
know are are great winners I got to show
you the times that you know they don't
work
out so you know you come down here to no
lows not really any reason to be buying
down here down here um get down here
Delta scalper again giving you a Buy
Signal then here you got a ratio and a
Divergence ratio and Divergence I talk
about this tell I'm blue in the face you
guys are probably sick of me hearing me
talk about it but again Delta scalper
that's a buying opportunity right on the
low ratio and Divergence and what do you
do you make a nice move up from you know
basically the uh 10 area all the way up
here to the 16 sort of hang around the
10 area so you could have got something
out of it you should have been able to
get something out of it before it starts
coming down lower but you know as you
can see what's changing here here you
got a lot of bullish ratios bullish
bullish bullish all of a sudden out here
you got bearish bearish bearish you we
should be able to recognize that you
know things are changing that we're
probably going to start coming back into
the lows again which we do you know you
don't see any bearish signals in here
nothing
basically get down here new low this is
10 o00 ratio blue number Divergence the
arrow so that's that's your sign to be
buying then here again you get another
another um bullish ratio you don't have
a Divergence though but again you know
you should still be long off of this bar
here then Delta scalper coming in again
right off the low and you know it's
similar to the 5 years you make this
nice move up you know but really you
should have been getting long somewhere
in here on the 15 152 area and it trades
all the way up above 12 you know up here
where we start going sideways and start
heading you know I'll say heading
heading into the Clos for the day but um
you once you got past uh 1:00 it just
really slowed down in here so you know
these are things I talk about every day
ratios and Divergence Delta scalper off
lows you know I did show you this Delta
scalper here um this one worked you know
this one worked but I showed you you
know again I went back a little early
6:30 here where Delta scalper didn't
work okay again I want you to see times
where it works times where it doesn't
work but again you'll look for signs in
the order flow that it's not going to
work okay next up is the uh snps and
this is a four range chart I show you
the four range I show you the 10 range
and yeah S&S were under pressure pretty
much the entire
session and you know I'll just go I'll
start the charts here around 5:30 in the
morning well okay 446 you know people
say oh yeah had a ratio and Divergence
that failed yeah it failed you came
right back with a bearish ratio right
afterwards again you know read the
orderflow that it's not going to work
out when you start seeing a a bearish
ratio after you get long it's probably
not going to be be a very effective
trade but anyway that's that's that's at
4: in the morning I'm not going to
discount it that it's at 4: in the
morning but um you know if you want to
count it go ahead count it it's a losing
trade uh you just go through so you know
after cash opens here
8:30 start coming into these lows got
Divergence here nothing no ratio no
ratio afterwards again there's no reason
bu you know people you see me talking
about buying off lows or selling off
highs people think well you're always
trying to pick highs and lows no I'm not
really what I'm doing is I'm I'm looking
for signs in the market that things are
changing okay I'm not trying to pick a
high I'm not trying to pick a low I'm
letting the market tell me that hey you
know you have a high here or hey you
have a low
here so there's no reason to be buying
off any of these lows here this low this
low but what you know what you can
notice here is you got Divergence that
fails Divergence that failed no
divergences here when I start seeing
multiple divergences that fail to me
that's a sign of the Market's trending
either higher or lower so already here
908 sorry 906 you get another Divergence
that fails so you know from 8 what time
is this 8:41 until 906 you know you've
already got three failed divergences in
a half hour I'd be looking for the
market once I see three for me it's like
three get ready to go um and get short
on the next time you come into the low
and boom you come into this low a little
bit later a minute
later strong selling IM balance selling
IM balance boom you both break right
through this low at 12 you got
immediately trade down to uh 10 and a qu
now this is interesting you come down
here you got a Divergence no ratio next
bar you got a ratio again I always talk
about when you get a Divergence and you
don't get the ratio in that bar look to
the next bar if you get the the ratio
and you get it and this made for a nice
little trade here probably like the the
easiest trade of the day honestly
um you know from 12 all the way up to
the 15 area before just sort of going
sideways start coming down and going
and rotating around uh the value
area yeah but that was that was the
really big uh to me that was the big
trade of the day now you get down here
right you got this big imbalance 2381
it's a selling imbalance and you see a
big b balance like that you expect the
market to be to sell off but what it's
telling you right it tells you sort of
the opposite thing it's telling you hey
there's some supportive buying down here
you know you got buyers coming in here
and bidding it as 16 2416 and we bounce
back up a bit here for the short term
then you get in here you got nice
stacked in Balance um you do rally up a
bit before it just Falls over again as
more selling comes in and look at the
selling imbalances all red red red red
red red all negative Delta you just know
it's going going to go
lower this is a nice bearish sign in
here and you again we come down into
lows you know late in the session um um
no failed divergences but again no
reason to be buying off these lows you
know as we're going lower so again it's
not just because we made a low I'm
looking for a reason to buy here you get
a failed ratio and Divergence as you
come down lower than here 4 245 you get
a ratio and a Divergence and this one
you get get a move so here you had one
that failed here you got one that works
so what's your risk you know your risk
is here from 07 down to um was that six
so um you know 5 and three quarter so
five ticks okay then again you're
getting long in here at 6 and
A2 and what does it do it trades all the
way up into the 09 area so um you know
you're risking five ticks and here you
got back
three uh what is that five ticks which
is one point and one tick and here
you're getting back you know two and a
half points so you're getting back
double more than double than than what
you risked on that
trade the 10 range chart
it was uh it was a bit interesting
actually um if I could find it
here gave some very nice uh nice trades
uh with the Delta scalper and I want to
talk about
those so anyway going back here to uh
what time is this here oops open this up
a little bit
here okay this is uh 838 Delta scalper
right here and getting
short you know around the 19 area and it
just sells off quite quite dramatically
there's no reason to be getting out of
this position here you have a a
Divergence but you know Divergence by
itself is not a big enough reason so you
know from 19 all the way down to you
know the 12 13 area here you get the
Delta scalper giving you a buy it comes
down here yeah it probably would have
stopped me out I I probably would have
taken the loss I don't like it when it
comes through the bottom of the the the
signal bar um then it makes a nice move
up so it's just unfortunate but then
later in the day 12:40 boom you hit this
swing High where is it right here and
then Delta scalper giving you another
cell right around that same level
actually he around here was 22 here it's
slightly lower this is uh 19
A2 well at least the high of this bar is
19 and A2 but again you know you're
getting short in here in the next bar
around 17 7 16 and A2 and what does it
do it trades right down to you know the
12 area so yeah it was giving you
something you know this one failed this
this Delta scalper signal failed here so
you had two fails but you had two nice
trades two nice winners you know then
down here you got the ratio and
Divergence and you know we work our way
back up right now it's I'm recording
this it's uh 2: a.m. Chicago time um and
you know we're training here at at 11:
so again you know from 08 all the way up
to
11 across two
sessions okay really quick uh this will
be the last one I going to talk about
this is crude um
okay so this is about 4: in the morning
5 in the morning Delta scalper and the
swing low Delta scalper bu 620 ratio and
Divergence so you got a nice Delta
scalper by it rallied from the uh 75 76
77 area all the way up to the '90s get a
bearish signal here here here you got
three ratios in a row um it does come
back up test the high again just sort of
go sideways but again you know if you're
trading at this time this is an eight
range chart so each bar is is nine ticks
this is you know you could at least got
you know close to 20 ticks out of that
trade um Delta scalper another buy it's
a little close to the high so you know
even though it's a winner I'm not sure I
I would you I don't like I like to take
shorts off of highs rather than buying
going into a high here you got a ratio
no diver here you got a Divergence no
ratio you get the ratio in the bar
afterwards just sort of goes sideways on
you alternating green red green red
green to me that's a sign the Market's
not really going anywhere and just to
you know faster I say faster get out but
really seriously considered getting out
you know if if the Market's not going
anywhere after you get into a trade it's
you know it's starts the trade reason
the reason you get into a trade really
starts losing its Effectiveness over
time right the market should move if
you're convinced that hey this is a
signal the market should move right it's
not going to just sort of rotate around
price I mean I say it shouldn't but I
mean it often can do that but if it does
that then you know the the the signals
Effectiveness or the reason for taking
the trade rather is um is basically
really losing its it's its Effectiveness
for the trade um 10:00 things got a bit
crazy anyway uh just look for some other
Delta scalper signals in
here okay so this is stacked imbalance
as already making a move
down the Delta scalper buys here so
there here's a nice sell here just
before noon Delta scalper
cell you know this is around you're
getting short somewhere around the 12
area you know rallies back up to 18
before selling off quite nicely from 12
boom boom boom boom boom boom there's no
reason to be buying in here if if
anything you just seeing more um what
you're seeing is
more reason to stay short you know
bearish ratio single print stacked
imbalance bearish ratio single print
yeah you got a green bar it's still
negative Delta negative Delta here here
um no reason to be buying you know if
you want you can cut your position but
you get down here you you got some signs
of positive Delta but this is a move
from you know 4612 all the way down to
4550 it's a 60c move in the crude before
you know you start seeing some positive
Delta you know Delta scoper giving you a
buy here but it's a red candle so you
know you really shouldn't be looking to
take it but now you start going sideways
you got point of controls you know sort
of lining up in here if you got out you
know there a little pre premature but
you know some at some point you're going
to get out um strong Delta starts
reappearing here - 900 - 600 - 600 as
you start uh going lower you get down
here now you got some signs of
life you hit the low nine you hit it
again 40 so you're testing the low you
didn't get through it which is
encouraging now you got a Delta scalper
giving you a buy got a Divergence so you
got positive Delta off the low look for
you know when you hit a low look to see
if you get any positive Deltas start to
come in and ideally if you're going to
move away from a low you're going to
want to see um positive Deltas over a
few bars and now you're starting to get
them here 1 2 3 um you know this Delta
scalper bu and it just starts to hang
around hang around hang around before it
starts working its way back up here it's
the Delta scalper cell but it's on a
green candle so you know you shouldn't
be taking it and you know so you come up
from that low at 18 all the way up into
the 40s or 50s up in
here um then we start working our way
back down and we end up closing you know
in here around uh what is that the 34
level in the evening session just more
selling coming in here just lower lower
lower um I don't want to talk about the
evening session but um but anyway guys
thanks for watching this this video I
said I have I didn't do my room this
week I'm having some technical issues
and I apologize if anyone was trying to
get into the room but I said I just got
some issues going on right now hope to
get them resolved pain in the butt but
um you know what can you do as
technology so thanks for watching this
again um I'm doing a webinar tomorrow or
sorry today time this video gets up
it'll be uh Friday July 7 at 12:15 p.m.
eastern time the registration link is
below in the description and um you know
sign up for it and you know get on the
the list for the replay if you can't
watch it I'll be I've got a quite nice
presentation I've been working on it uh
for the last couple
days so uh if can't then you can't you
know visit my website orderflows docomo
per.cup so thank you bye-bye